everyone it's my fault Elsa and welcome
to the order flows market analysis for
Wednesday August 30th 2017 and stocks
firmed today Nasdaq was up over 1% Dow
had a marginal gain 0.1% and crude oil
another large draw in the weekly
inventories but it didn't really give
crude much of a lift and crude ended up
falling about 50 cents to just under $46
we had a very strong GDP number which
was good
came in at 3.3 percent for a consumer
spending so you know there was some very
nice trading opportunities in the SPS it
started out kind of slow morning as we
were hovering right around yesterday's
value area high and we sold off we were
higher than yesterday's value area high
but then we sold off into it just before
the cash open and we just sort of stayed
in there and again I was feeling if we
get a get above it then we could get a
nice rally and we did get a nice rally
but anyway before we jump into
everything's go over a brief disclaimer
this presentation is for educational and
informational purposes only and should
not be considered a solicitation to buy
or sell a futures contract or make any
other type of investment decision
futures train contain substantial risk
and is not for every investor an
investor could potentially lose all or
more than the initial investment risk
capital is money that could be lost
without jeopardizing one's financial
security or lifestyle only risk capital
should be used for trading and only
those with sufficient risk capital
should consider trading past performance
is not necessarily indicative of future
results and again you know every day the
market presents you know different
trading opportunities and no.2
opportunities in order flow is going to
be exactly alike they'll be similar but
you know what volume changes you know
who's participating changes all the time
so it's you know well things are similar
they're not fully exact now the tools
using this presentation are the order
flows trader and the Delta scalper the
order flows trader is the volume
footprint chart the Delta scalper is an
additional indicator that will run on
the order closed trader as well as a
normal bar chart so don't don't get the
Delta scalper thinking you're going to
get the volume footprint right
work that way right it's an additional
indicator it's completely separate so
that said let's let's jump into the
charts first market no no no can we keep
this short today
first market talk about is the e-mini I
said you know it got that nice nice
rally and I'll take a look at the ten
range chart here let me grab it real
quick okay here it is and there was a
couple of really standout opportunities
haha just disappeared on me really you
know with the order flow you know at the
high and as you're going up to the high
coming off the low and straight up to
the high if I could find this damn chart
which is going on here okay here it is
so I keep going back to the middle of
the night two in the morning we've made
our high here okay rallied up two in the
morning you hit or high you got a ratio
no divergence you do have the price
rejector that's this red line you do
have next bar the Delta scalper given a
signal
you've got side by side pointed controls
obviously two down bars the bar after
high strong negative Delta the bar on
your high kind of a neutral Delta in
terms of you know being a ten range
charge 389 is considered small so you
got some signs up here that this market
is gonna start selling off okay so
you're not convinced yet say you're not
convinced ah you know what
odor flow is for the birds I'm not
convinced that this is a high I'm gonna
buy and get long why why what sign is
there for you to be buying thinking
we're going to come back up and take off
this high there is none instead right
here you got this strong negative Delta
say you're not convinced here you wait
for this bar down again a nice strong
negative Delta 15 63 and you got you're
starting to see multiple imbalances yet
a couple here which is nice but then you
get another one two three in this bar so
by now you should be convinced you've
got lower point of control the markets
headin down whether you want to admit it
or not you could fight it all you want
but it is it's it's heading lower I mean
there's no point trying to be a hero
saying
think this markets gonna rally I should
buy there's absolutely no reason to
think after this bar that this market is
going to come up here and take out this
high right now or anytime soon there's
nothing in the order flow indicating
that instead all everything is in the
canyon this markets going lower and what
happens is you sell-off down down down
into the lows now this blue line here is
yesterday's value area high okay now
when we reopened we poked down in then
we shot straight up for the entire Asian
session so what I'm watching is when we
come back down into it what's the market
gonna do and it did it right you know
right ahead of the cash open this is
7:40 this morning this bar closed and
then you know 8 o'clock 8 17 836 837
we're just hanging around inside you
know inside the upper end of yesterday's
value area so you know the point of
control actually for yesterday I think
was somewhere in here around 45 if I
remember correctly I've thought my head
I mean I can take a look but I don't
think that's important yet here 46 was
yesterday's point of control but anyway
I don't think that's important as the
value area high since it's so close so
we're just hanging around there right so
you know when you come in back into
yesterday's value area what's gonna
happen are we just gonna hang around in
there or are we gonna go sell off all
the way down to the lower value area
probably not in this case or we're gonna
rally back out of the value area like we
did earlier today last night and we
started coming up around 9 o'clock and
what do you got down here you know you
got divergence you got divergence you've
got a ratio and the next bar you don't
have a ratio in this bar but divergence
and ratio again you know me saying this
every day people I think they're sick of
me here and sick of me saying it but
again you know watch when you get ratios
and divergence if you don't get the
ratio in the bar with the divergence
look to the next bar for the ratio and
you're getting it and then you start
rallying excuse me start rallying up
you're above the value area high from
yesterday which is good sign that we go
be high and be going higher you're
getting higher pointing controls one two
three now you got green bars everything
you know positive deltas 1500 mm
and you got one bar here with negative
Delta okay that's one bar it doesn't
necessarily mean the entire move is over
watched what happens the next part this
next bar comes back really quick it
takes six minutes to finish this bar
coming to the next part and I stacked by
an imbalance okay so now like earlier I
was telling you you didn't have any
reason to be getting long up near that
high now you're at the short and you got
every reason to believe that we're gonna
start rallying you got your divergence
you've got your ratio afterwards another
ratio here you got string a positive
Delta is coming in you're above
yesterday's value area high there's
absolutely no reason to think that you
this market is gonna sell off and start
making new lows anytime soon it's just
not you know the signs are just not
there and what happens is we start
rallying boom you get the stack buying
in balance and it holds you know I'd
love to see you guys bullish ratio here
just to confirm it that we're not you
know anything markets knock us off and
then look at these deltas all positive
Delta four thousand nine hundred eight
thousand eight thousand do you see any
min Delta's in here no you don't you
just see zero zero zero so at no point
in these bars were there any net
aggressive selling you know there's
obviously aggressive selling into the
bids but it's not enough to turn the
Delta negative at any point and that's
also important the new rally up here you
got a bunch of imbalances one two three
four this next bar one two three so you
got you know you're staring at seven
imbalances now you get up here to these
highs and what do you get now you've got
a stacked selling a balance here at the
high you've got a divergence you've got
point to control up near the high so
you're starting to see a bunch of
bearish signs up here you don't have the
ratio next part you do have the ratio
and then you can you got a nice negative
Delta so looking at the market at this
point what do you think this markets
gonna do you think this markets gonna
rally still you know you think we just
hit this high coming off and then poke
back up no you shouldn't think that you
got all negative signs up here
divergence pointing control near the
high stacked imbalance a big selling
imbalance right off the high ratio in
the next bar stronger negative Delta in
the second bar four thousand strong by
itself five thousand is even stronger so
you got all the signs
there's markets gonna be selling off so
what happens it starts trading lower you
do rally back up towards this point of
control I'd you know the one thing about
this bar is it would look a hell of a
nicer if this point of control was a
little bit lower but what you can see in
here is quite a bit of volume 5,000 up
here at 8 and 1/4 which tells you that
there is supply so the market started
rallying back up but there's somebody in
there selling the out of it you
know 5,000 that's a decent chunk you
know at this area normally now before
you got up there he had you know
nineteen hundred three thousand four
thousand now you got five thousand so
it's a bit strong then boom it sell off
well for selling imbalances in that part
very strong negative Delta but really
the signs were here earlier you know so
you be getting short somewhere in this
bar and this bar is a nice down bar and
you run in here right before the cash
closed you know you sort of poke back up
and then you go into the evening session
where we are right now but again you
should have been looking to get short in
this bar I don't know how she could have
gotten out of this but really you know
the best trade you know there's nice
this was the best one here this morning
you had a lot more going for it in terms
with taking in yesterday's value area
high as well so you know if you're
getting along in here you know you got a
beautiful move up to the new highs this
one here yeah as a small move it just as
you know earlier the overnight session
you had a nice little move here as well
so you know everything today worked out
nicely in the espys ok think looking at
crude really quick again you know 9:30
you had the inventory numbers came out
you had you know another large draw and
you think actually get a you got a
little sell-off and then you shot up to
new highs and then you sold off but at
this low here 943 again you know what do
you got here you get you know small
Delta you got positive Delta those so
you got the divergence next bar you got
the ratio that you're looking for again
you know I just showed you in the SPS
and I'm showing it to again in the crude
oil and what do you get
Delta scalper as well off the low which
is a nice sign next bar all you know
I'll say all binding balances but you
know over half the bar is fine and
balances and you shoot up to I mean I'll
say you shoot up at this point you get
up to the swing high is to come back in
its kind of go sideways again oh no
reason to be you know getting short in
here I mean other than this Delta
scalper but you come down in here you've
got you know a zero print which is
bullish then you start going back up
okay I'll see you if you're long off
this Delta scalper off the low you run
into here you you'd be getting short and
it just goes sideways on you I don't
think you would have caught the move up
but then you're starting coming in here
and what do you get you got a stack
binding balance followed by another
stack vine imbalance which again you
know you got one right after the other
you should be thinking there's a lot of
aggressive vine in here you should be
able to recognize that and it's worth a
shot it's worth a shot getting long you
know if it was just one binding balanced
stacked binding balanced like this one
by itself I wouldn't be too interested
but now you've got two in a row I'm a
little bit more interested and we do
have some room coming in to the high so
it's again it's not look at all this and
these are nice aggressive bars in terms
of buying buying you know eight hundred
nine hundred a thousand six hundred and
here it starts waning but it picks up
again 650 four hundred eight hundred as
you're making these new highs you get up
here to this high strong negative Delta
you know the bar right before it you've
got a small Delta 63 but then you get
this high you've got the divergence you
got the Delta scalper you've got
multiple you know two imbalances one
seventy nine three five four racial in
the next bar so you're getting the signs
in here to be getting short okay and
you're at your high so if you're getting
short off your high yeah yours your stop
is just behind the high so you're not
risking too much you know maybe 10 ticks
on this trade to be getting short okay
what happens is the market just sort of
meanders go sideways starts heading down
again you know if you're getting short
somewhere you know in here or on the 60
area I said you know your stops up here
at 70 do you see any signs in here that
you know there's aggressive mind that
this market could start going up no
there's nothing stingy as you see in
bearish ratio here starts coming
finally nice strong deltas 700-800
you know just really quick you know here
he had some nice positive deltas 1500
1100 but the market can't go any higher
it's just it's people are buying the
out of it but they're sellers up
there okay that should be telling you
something when you got these very strong
deltas and the markets not going up
that's a negative sign
you know that's it's just telling you
there there's people that have offers up
there you know people that have supply
they're offering it out people are
buying it but they can't get past that
supply now if the market started going
higher there'd be another story but the
fact is it's being it's holding down the
market and then the market sells off
boom boom boom keep selling off keep
selling off you know even here you get
the deltas and can no reason to be
buying in here yep now here you got a
bullish ratio but you know what that's
just one out of out of all these bars
that's nothing and anything you have
this little yet this you know trap
traders down here you do get a little
pop up you know trap traders from you
sort of a is a short-term trade and you
know Delta scalper again you know
telling you to stay short and you go
into the clothes you end up closing
around 46 bucks so no slightly under 46
bucks but I can you know the signs were
there of selling that high you know I
would love to say there was there was a
lot of clear signs that you could have
caught the entire move up but you sort
of ran into you know some bearish signs
on the way up but then once you continue
to move up you got a nice bullish sign
here with these buying imbalances so you
least catch you know the other half of
the move but definitely up here at this
high you should have been able to
recognize this the structure up here
with with all the bearish signs right
before the market sold off okay so you
know the day wouldn't be complete
without an obligatory a nice Delta
scalper chart so I'll show you this this
is the e-mini 987 tick chart you know
the sell doesn't work out but I don't
think it would have because you didn't
get the follow-through in the next bar
right next bar opened up and traded
higher
all right I like to let the market lead
me in there like here this one you know
is a nice sell but then it came right
back with a nice buy and boom you know
49 all the way up to the 58 area where
you got the cell the cells these cells
didn't work out you sort of went
sideways and stopped you out
here's nice little buy starts coming
down if you're trailing your stop maybe
you would caught something there same
thing here and they'll probably break
even with your stop but again you know
even if you're losing you know one tick
on this one point here on this trade one
point on this trade one point on this
trade you just got you know nine points
so you willing to risk you know this
one's on the cash close on the cash
close you really get a big wave of
buying or selling so you do get
sometimes very big delta numbers which
is I think it's just little skew it a
little bit that's why I'm a little bit
hesitant to take trades right on the
cash close because I know that's what
everyone is walking by and coming in
buying and selling you know right on the
cash close but again you know are you
going to risk you know one point two
points three points three losing trades
for a trade they potentially get you
know nine ten points on you know
everyone says you got to have two to one
three to one risk reward ratio well
here's a nine to one risk reward you
know sure when you have a ninety one
risk reward not every trade is going to
be a winner right don't expect if you're
trading with such a high risk to reward
ratio that you're gonna get a high
winning percentage you're not even get a
smaller winning percentage because
you're trying to catch bigger moves
alright
you know sometimes people don't really
grasp that they think I'm gonna have a
nine to one you know ten to one risk
reward ratio and get you know sixty
percent winners you're not you're just
not you know it boggles my mind that
some people think that way but you know
people think that way what can you do
you know just really quick let's see if
I could just show you another another
chart again you know 233 tick charts in
the crude I I don't advocate trading
this for a lot of people because you're
gonna be taking a shitload of trades I
said the only reason I put this here is
because you know some guy was being a
jerk
me you say Delta scalper doesn't really
work so even if you're traded you know
in the evening session let me look at
this this is 3:00 in the morning 2:00 in
the morning yeah you got a cell here it
doesn't really trigger you to get in and
then here you get a nice cell you know
from the 34 area down into the 14 areas
you know 20 points and at 2:00 in the
morning
you know then here you're getting a lot
of back and forth back and forth that
let's see what looks like after the
inventory number again it's just sort of
going back and forth then here okay so
yeah nothing here back and forth
breakevens yeah I mean you know this one
you're talking you know what's your
what's your risk you know say you're
getting short in here at OU 8 you know
if you're using 5 or 6 ticks you know
you're probably okay it's hard to say
you know this one comes in here then you
get the buy here then you get the nice
buy from you know the 14 the 15 level
and what happens is it trades all the
way up into the 45 area where you get a
sell so you know that's 30 ticks right
there get the cell doesn't work out it
sort of scratches then you get your
another entry at 45 up to 65 it's
another 20 tick so it's 50 cents are you
there you just got so if you're risking
five six ticks I mean you know some of
these you'd be breaking even maybe
losing one or two ticks or three ticks
trailing your stops I can you got to
understand your risk to reward ratio you
know but again at 233 tick charges is
going to be very very fast you know
you're gonna get shitload of trades
later in the day and a nice sell-off I
mean I don't I don't think that's a
beautiful chart but again I don't think
you know people I don't know why people
would want to twenty to thirty three
tick chart it's going to be moving
extremely extremely fast I prefer you
know something that's not gonna give me
a heart attack in the markets now I'll
show you a better a better chart he's at
eight range British Pound chart look at
this a nice buy here sells up yet I sell
down here
nice nother bye comes back up you know
so these you know this one is probably
break even this one
you know maybe got you know something of
your future a few ticks out of not a
whole lot you know let's see here let's
go through it you know say you're buying
it here at 21 you get your cell here you
know so that's 10 ticks this one you
know where you get insured at somewhere
in here at 31 32 and it comes back up so
you know that ones by about breakeven
then you get a nice cell here you know
you're getting short here say 31 32
cells all the way you know it sells off
quite nicely you get this nice move down
your trail on your stop starts coming
back up so you know you're short at 30
you know maybe you're covering it around
7 8 9 10 you know so there was some nice
nice points if you had there in the
British Pound but anyway I'd I don't
want to keep this too long try not to
keep these videos too long cause I don't
lose people's attentions so to learn
more about trading software order flows
go to WWF lows to learn more about the
Delta scalper visit Delta scalper comm
so thanks everyone and have a great day
bye-bye